for
mhm
hello there we
go one second let me figure out how to
do
computer
yep
good all right now
screen goes
here this goes here very good computer
very
good
hello
good hello qar all right
now screen goes
here this goes here very good
so today I thought uh I
could chat a bit because I've promised
an open Assistant end
stream and uh that's what we're doing
today and at the same time we're going
to look a little bit into the code base
of the hugging face Hub um it's open
source so very good we'll just Snoop
around a little bit to see what we find
uh I
could yeah it's goodbye I've made a
video on it and um
assist we collected our data set and
it's it's G well we're and we don't want
the project to become a zombie so we'd
rather you know do the next the next
cool thing we'll just Snoop around this
is complete I
could yeah it's goodbye I've made a
video on it and um let's see we
collected our data set and it's it's
gone that's probably better
now yeah the echo is going to stop I
hope let me let me know if it
stops yeah echo echo echo I'm sorry
there
is so I have this I have myself here as
you
see maybe I can turn this off too good
okay um yeah so open Assistant has
stopped stopped concluded uh so I think
we've collected tons of data and now
this is very good
and I think it was a really good time to
do that uh what do you use your head is
really shiny I have like two big lamps
here and another big lamp there and my
head doesn't have a lot of hair so all
of that mix is is making it very
shiny that that's that's that
um yeah
so the uh we we feel like it was really
like there was a lot of momentum at when
chat GPT came out to do open source
stuff around it and there was nothing
open source
and uh I believe we've we really did a
good job of
capturing that
momentum because there was a real danger
of you know many many different projects
starting all doing like something
something little and uh there therefore
never really never taking off and I
think we've captured the moment mum well
and we captured all of these people
willing to do work and um that's now
what it is and I think I feel we've done
we've done a good job
so but now obviously you know there's
tons of Open Source stuff there's new
ways of creating other data sets
synthetic or non-synthetic and so on
people figuring out new things and
obviously also a lot of people moving on
to different things uh open Assistant
needed tons of human labor like
moderating the whole platform going
after all the flagged messages and so on
so that's just not to feasible anymore
um you watch videos with 8 toight mons
delay the intro video was just a week
ago I'm so sorry uh it so the one week
the one week was a glorious week uh yeah
that's the situation um we're pretty
happy with how it came to be
uh it means no more openness it like the
models are all available like the data
is all available and um we're finishing
up the like the final data that we've
gotten since the release of the first
data and yeah everything's everything's
available so what we no longer do is
we've turned off like we turned off the
chat interface for a while because there
are now tons and tons of places where
you can chat with any anything that's on
the hugging face Hub and uh the open
Assistant models are on the Hub so you
you can chat with them pretty much in
many places and therefore we felt we
don't want to waste sponsor money and it
was also a giant mess to keep running
right like keeping a keeping a
distributed inference system running
with the token streaming and so on that
was a pain a pain
and then on top of that obviously
keeping the data collection running with
the moderation and so on and all the the
bugs people reported it so on it was it
was something and it was cool but you
know with time fewer and fewer people
came which is completely understandable
and so I think we made the best the best
out of it
um yeah so and I think still today I
think didn't it didn't like open chat 35
or so based
on like some of these new models they
have the open Assistant data inside of
them which is cool
um yeah can you go over the source code
of open
Assistant that is probably I can
probably um let's see wait I'm going to
turn off the the screen for a bit bit
here
um let's see what we can
do probably can what's next let's
see there is an alternate reason I'm
going over the hugging face OB source
code
uh um yeah cool so the open assistance
it's so much right the it has grown and
I have I have only written part of this
or touched part of this myself and very
people who are way more competent than I
am have written uh a large part of it so
I don't want to um I don't want to take
credit for any of this or even take
credit for knowledge of any of this like
I largely this largely goes over over my
head so what I know well is this
inference system right here um the the
inference
system had a
few uh a few things that were special
about it so for one there is the front
end I didn't have to implement because
that's in the website I implemented this
text client right here and that's just
very simple that's like a command line
utility that uh will connect and will'll
get you like it's it's super simple you
just you connect you uh enter a message
and you get back the tokens but then the
difficult parts are for one the workers
so the workers
are you could see it already
goes the workers are
when
huh when
you the worker runs on a machine with a
GPU right and the worker is what
actually produces the stuff but then
obviously because we had different
sponsors of hardware and so this had to
run in a distributed fashion and we also
had this idea at some point that uh even
people with the GPU at home could run a
worker and therefore this also had to
have an aspect of security and
verification uh that you would probably
not have in a normal system like this
although that never was never activated
but the design has this in mind
um Nvidia chip Nemo made heavy use of
open Assistant data really
nice um wanted to know whether I should
look into to build research aptitude for
llms I'm I'm not sure what that means
but the the the whole should I do this
should I do that whatever is interesting
to you what's your thoughts about Bill
Gates saying GPT 5 won't be any better
than GPT
4 out of his experience with successive
versions of Windows probably yeah not
everyone is like you Bill Gates people
can actually make better software over
time
um when you get Clon and takes five
minutes I'm
sorry
um about making big project with
scripts no no
idea how you design the scripting I I
have no clue
um to really tell you what the open
assistant is if you ask this then it's
no longer relevant it's it's over uh
it's a data collection
project
going over the core ml for making a
startup no no just like if if you if if
you're unfamiliar with core machine
learning and you are already wanting to
do a startup now it's it's better to go
with a company that just relies on API
calls um you know there's there's tons
of competent people around and takes a
while to learn are you going to NPS next
week yeah I hope so I have everything
scheduled but you know there's always
emergencies so I don't
know okay so the worker uh the
worker yada yada yada handles work
requests okay so he gets a work request
uh here the work
request it says you know the request
type is
work that that's someone okay let's Also
let's also so turn on
um let's turn on flame just so we can
see who made this oh it was me of
course uh okay it then it then gets a
thread which is kind of the conversation
so far right uh with
messages and it gets um created that it
gets some parameters to do work and the
parameters are the models how to do
sampling what the seed is and so on uh
what the system prompt is user profile
so this essentially is everything the
worker needs to know to produce a
response right including a seed you saw
including a seed and the seed is part of
the of the system that actually then
makes some security happen uh safety
parameters
um worker
request okay okay good so
we were at here so it gets a a request
and the config for the worker itself
like how many parallel requests it can
handle what model is it running
so plugins okay that's not my doing uh
whether it's using plugins or not
then safety also we can skip that for
now then the lurm IPO model will just
generate some lurm events and other than
that we'll truncate the prompt
and
uh we get inference service stream
events so this assumes that in the
background there is a hugging face
inference server running like a TGI text
generation inference server and I've
made a live stream where I built
streaming into that which is now a core
part of the inference server which is
really cool uh so beyond the open
Assistant data set the streaming inside
of hogging face the text generation
inferences is maybe one thing that came
out of this as well so
uh yeah we stream stuff and we get the
stream
events and uh we send we send back the
events and then there is a whole bunch
of llama specific code because at that
point there wasn't there weren't there
weren't good L like the Llama tokenizers
for some reason they had some issues oh
no it's
because you want to send back token by
token right but sometimes you need
multiple tokens to actually decode the
correct thing uh so I implemented this
token buffer to kind of buffer
tokens and so you send them back with a
delay of stuff eh we hacked around a lot
of things because back then you didn't
have good tooling around llama and so on
when llama came out um sorry I'm not
keeping
up are you excited about rnn's making a
comeback I wasn't sure they are
uh yeah they always have the same
problems like back propop through time
is very noisy and
inefficient so it that's not going to
change
um he's nine months behind you
uh that's fine I feel like I feel like
having an arbitrary pause compared to
the rest of the world it's kind it's
it's Unique it makes you experience life
in a different Cadence than the rest of
the world right um
so
like you go through life but you kind of
know that 9 months from now stuff is
still okay so at least Doom it like the
world world Dom ation hasn't happened or
will not happen in the next 9 months as
you experience the world that's what you
know that's kind of good
no um it
yeah as contributing in Portuguese it
was very fun thank you for contributing
U the future legality of the open source
sides uh I have no clue I'm not a
lawyer um question
isn't a Jason speeding
up it's it's Jason yeah it's Jason um so
the the protocol here is using pantic
and then fast API and so on and pantic
serializing to Jason so the query for
openis has grammatical
mistake if the query has grammatical
mistake how does it figure stuff out I
guess
mostly it's fine fine language models
can deal with grammatical
mistakes um sorry my Intel GPU this
streaming times out on first inference
have to let it time out on
what okay yeah that's cool the future of
ml
Engineers look uh
sorry Engineers software Engineers
they're still going to be around it's
going to be fine it's going to be be
totally
fine um do you think rlf is good sure
Schmid Uber is coming back well he
already claims credit for qar
so um llama changed everything yeah we
only had pythia that's true that's
absolutely
true longtime fan thank you um option to
produce highly specialized small
models yeah that's the question right um
I I I am I'm more skeptical about
specialized small models
because they still require like even
even if you feel like let's take a human
who's like super specialized in one
particular task still that human
benefits from having like a general
knowledge because even in the context of
that one particular task that general
knowledge will kind of come in a lot of
times and therefore the larger models
might still be better at it um yeah
obviously a large model fine tuned for a
particular task might be even better but
I'm not sure whether the small models
are going to be a good good option in
all the cases in some for sure what's
next I don't know
uh yeah make more videos I hope I've I I
don't have time that much time anymore
so open AI goodbye
stream
another
coup why goodbye well we finished the
project n too sensitive to prompt
quality I have no I have no idea other
people know way more about that than me
what's next for you don't
know I haven't heard anything about qar
yeah
uh gp5 AGI for sure for for
sure with regards to mini models have
you heard thira no no idea what is open
Assistant don't worry about it your re
made Ubers Soul paper it looks like a
Transformer well if if it has Matrix
multiplies and I get it like the fast
weight stuff yes but
but it's about
execution when we the context window be
large enough for model take its entire
parameter set take in its entire
parameter
ooh that's a good
idea okay what okay okay like a model
that takes in its own entire parameter
set ha what interesting stuff could we
do with
that as input right
and then what do we train it
for you you
know it's an interesting it's an
interesting thought to
follow like what weird thing could you
do if you take the parameters and you
make that into the input of the model
and then what that's the question I
guess
uh there's a what's the Emoji stuff is
ah yeah
okay thesis on COD Lage
I running 34b code llama locally yeah
well I would guess it's a it's a big
model
so thoughts on vide absurd pricing for
accelerators well it's demand and Supply
so uh
yeah you could do it with an input of an
LM to try learning to modify exactly
certain part sure but then I mean what
you you would have to have the bottle
parameters and the
input as an input right and then what do
you do you just train language modeling
because at that point it's no longer or
or you train the you train the gradient
update to the parameters or something
I'm not
sure create an improved self
clone
yeah yeah so you you take a language
model you run gradient descent right you
record all the intermediate stages and
then that is a sequence again
right and then you train a language
model on that sequence that's
not that is that sounds it sounds like
completely useless but funny so it might
be something that a YouTuber would
actually
do uh yeah yeah I mean there is a whole
whole literature on um actually
interpreting great like optimization
algorithms as sequential problems and
then uh like learning them with like an
RNN and it wasn't rainbow or something
like this uh these types of
papers yeah so I think there is a whole
lot of precedent for that kind of stuff
um I'm just more looking for something
that's even more
useless
so
yeah what's the next project I don't
know I don't know
all right continuing the code there's a
whole bunch of llama handling as you can
see here there's a bunch of locks around
for tokenizers not sure if we need them
okay Oliver put that in so we probably
need
them
uh yeah there's the token buffer and
[Music]
um yeah then we we just we just kind of
send the response by the way the the the
worker and the um Central server they're
connected via VIA websocket so that the
worker will initiate the connection to
the server and then they'll maintain a
websocket connection whereas the
connection from TGI to the worker is an
HTTP call with a event stream uh
response as is the web front end to the
inference uh back end and that gets an
event stream and in between there's a a
redis reddis
database so sorry I'm mildly mildly
mucus
producing all right more llama
stuff and then send a
response okay so yeah so the this is
built that the individual token or the
individual events are like streamed over
the websocket one by one and then at the
end you put the full generated text and
you put also some metrics so here we
grab uh um we
grab whatever all kinds of metrics from
the workers and send them back as
well plugins and so
on oh yeah I built this in so that I can
see what batch size uh we should do so
this uh essentially makes a goes and
makes a longer and longer input so we
can figure out what the max length is we
can do on individual
gpus
yep okay that's the worker the worker
isn't too bad right essentially just
does a difference but then the
server that's that's terrible it's
really
terrible um how long do you think it
will tape you have a complete view of
what happened at open AI 3 never you'll
never know
uh GPD for Chan
V2 it's no longer interesting like
anyone can do that nowadays you you
spend I don't know $20 on Laura and uh
takes you an hour or
two when was the point in the open
Assistant project when you decided to
wrap it up I I don't know at the end
when we re like when we saw you know the
contributions were kind of
um smaller and we ourselves were you
know didn't have the capacity anymore to
do it we've and then we thought it was a
good time to wrap it up uh which is
fair um because yeah we we'd rather the
people who contribute which are like you
know amazing people uh who have just
invested their free time into this um we
want them to you know have done
something that's good worthwhile and and
not use their kindness any longer than
necessary like any more than necessary
like we we feel that kindness is better
allocated in other projects uh from now
on and I think you know successive
successive projects all with a finished
date um make for a better better
trajectory looking at the just hit me
looking at the am I I'm going to create
my own AI I will name it Skynet that's a
that's a good
idea FPA training any good I don't know
I have no clue over uh Quant
quantization as far as I'm
aware people go down to like three or
four bits nowadays but I'm not sure if
they already train with it or if that's
just post talk
quantization the emergence of a world
model inside llms
yeah that's a good question right
how how much or let's
assume
uh let's assume some model is like
really good at language modeling right
the model today already are quite good
let's assume one is really good how
necessary is it to actually build an
internal World model to do that I don't
know that's it's probably an interesting
question to
research um like whether that just
emerges inside of these models it
probably has to right if it's good at
language modeling it probably has to
have some sort of an internal World
model so do we see the
emergence I would guess yes but then
it's it's also the question what what is
that even mean without obviously the
humans not only do they have a world
model they also have like
self-reflection Consciousness and so on
to be able to ask themselves about the
world model in their head so it's
questionable
to consider what happens without those
things what does it even
mean can you point out any similar
project if you go to the open Assistant
website you'll find uh links to other
projects to
contribute
um started training their models in 8
bit that's cool that's okay five bit is
pretty good that yeah can believe are
you interested in
interpretability
um a bit honestly I most
interpretability stuff is it's a
fundamental problem right because
you like unless un there is a concept of
unnecessary complexity
like nurs papers especially older ones
they just maybe still they just have
math for the sake of math and that's
kind of unnecessary complexity but a lot
of problems especially when you learn
them uh with you know neuron networks
and so on some of them just have
inherent complexity and the
interpretability techniques they always
kind of assume some sort of problem
structure which is not necessarily given
especially for the ones that have
inherent complexity like there
is it is possible for problems to have
an inherent complexity such that they
just aren't easily interpretable right
and then the interpretability methods
they will still give you some kind of
answer
so in an ironic sense these methods
aren't always super
interpretable
um open Assistant the chat interface is
disabled yes yes I know I know can LM
give directions and a map can certainly
give directions doesn't doesn't say if
if they are uh
good I'm going to miss watching your
videos uh I'll continue producing
videos I'll
continue thoughts on the hotter price um
compression capabilities well hter is
exact compression
right um and and there for it's like
it's for it's for sure good
um to have a quantity like this because
you can measure it exactly but then also
if as soon as you talk about exact
compression
um you're so much outside of the domain
of what is mostly relevant which is in
exact compression like
uh semantically meaningful compression
let's say like to to Output the same
things in a semant like in the in the
relevant way and all of these terms are
super undefined obviously but humans
will remember information and transmit
information that they believe you know
like they if they compress it they'll
say the important bits right and that is
super vague but it's almost orthogonal
to as soon as you as soon as you demand
exact
compression H essentially you're an
information
Theory like you can't you can't use most
of what's useful about a language
model because no matter how well you
understand text uh you still have to
remember the exact words in exact
compression
um I believe some people are already
trying to extract other things than
words
okay po just seems excited about his new
algorithm yeah
okay what a
surprise I've not seen it by the way so
maybe I'm May I'll be excited
to
um have you heard of hyperdimensional
computing I think I've heard that term
but no what's your day-to-day job e no I
am a part of a of a startup of a
software
startup
um some protocols
but I was here you
were llm engines changing their API
method to open
AIS
well yeah there're there're it's good if
there is a standard right and
uh so and at the beginning of this field
it's kind of the biggest player that
decides what that standard is it's you
know in the early days it was the
Netscape Navigator uh and in these days
it's open
AI which is fine right um certainly
gives opena a bit of an advantage but
standardization is is okay and it's a
smart move because what it means that if
you're using the open AI API you can
just easily switch over to these other
things and it will just
work bu can beat the original Pokemon
games there is look there is
um not the original but there is a
project and it's been advertised on our
Discord
server uh that tries where people try to
do
that uh so I can't exactly tell you what
it's called but in like the promotion
channel of our Discord you should find a
reference to that and you're also you're
also free to uh you know look on on our
server for people who or on that server
for people who who are
interested opinions on
xlsm need to look it up if you
experimented with fine- tuning multiple
or adapters for the same model on
different data sets each adapter covers
a different tasks I mean people have
been I have not people have been doing
this stuff for tons and tons and tons of
uh places in in different different ways
and so on there's even a hypothesis that
character Ai and so on they do this for
their stuff and personalization so it's
possible um lon's objective driven AI
sure is open a trying to standardize
their protocol just the fact that it's
popular it's probably just the fact that
it's popular they're trying to make
money so they'll just do whatever they
feel they can do or that is good what is
the good buy for uh the open Assistant
project is the Discord open uh you'll
have to join yeah but it's um it's open
is you can
join you see Rags as a big update to
llms now they have nothing nothing to do
with each
other uh like R is like G is the llm and
R is the
retrieval like they're you can use them
together sure
but could you give a road map suggestion
for someone starting out on the ml
Journey uh it's very tricky look is like
right now it's very tricky you can hack
around with large language models and
you'll be fine or you can start with
Bishop pattern recognition and you'll
probably be fine it's more mathematical
or you can start out with like Benjo
good fellow deep learning and will also
be
fine like ml has been become a lot uh
like very
diverse H claims in the podcast that
they're trying to prove the scaling laws
of the algo has not published yet sure
okay all right you think that we can't
make better models by only focusing on
cognition and not Consciousness what
what like
focusing we're focusing on on uh
self-supervision right and
arguably Consciousness has arisen in
humans somehow so it's quite conceivable
that it arises in these
models what is happening is open
Assistant closing has closed yes has
concluded um open source is dead no it's
not it's more alive than ever
uh it's sure yes it's fueled by
corporate
in part but the open source spaces in
the large language model domain and the
assistant model domain is more
accessible and open than
ever Jan's talk about human Intelligence
being highly specialized and that
everybody is hyping
AGI somehow think he's right what's your
take well it defines like some
the only tangible definition of AGI
is better than a human in sort of human
relevant tasks and then that argument is
mov let's
see oh geez okay going more through the
code we
have uh I'm what I'm trying to find is
uh the big
the
giant the giant routing thing
so no these are front end routes this is
the back end
route so the worker will call out to
here to the back end um to this and
thereby establish a
websocket
and
yeah oh yeah this is this is the meat
here this is this is the terrible part
of the code now nowadays I would do this
way differently um but but this is how I
did it then uh in some energy drink fuel
nights uh as I said I sadly don't know
the other parts of the code base so the
data collection part is actually
engineered quite well other the
inference
part uh but that's because other people
than me have done it is there a copy
left license for data sets
um it's hard because it's questionable
whether copyright applies to data sets
right um but you can try to make one
uh do you think constraint decoding is
interesting to explore yes and no like
yes for sure you can make the model
decode some stuff but also no because
you it's it's probably not what people
imagine it is uh by restraining it to
these kinds of tokens you you kind of
make very weird effects and therefore
it's not
like yeah it's not it's not what people
imagine people imagine I want the most
likely thing out of this set of things
but it's probably not what's happening
um but I mean it's kind of what's
happening but I would be careful with
interpretation of what comes out of a
constrained decoding uh
decoder Left Right models can't be
AGI we need something this why not
humans go forward in time so
hey
hi uh what's the probability AGI will go
nuclear my opinion zero I'm a p Doom
equals zero kind of
person what will happen when every human
gets one AGI robot which will then do
all the work for the human will we just
Netflix and
chill I
probably I don't know this is so this is
so
unrealistic is there any work being done
to solve the Black Box problem not sure
what that
means on a different note seen a lot of
businesses spring out of postco targeted
GPT rapper Market but it seems pretty
fruitless yep yep you're absolutely
right there's tons and tons of GPT
rappers not rappers with a W not rappers
with an
R
he seemed not really concerned about
elia's fears of AI safety was it because
you thought the main motivator Sam's
ating was his closest to it's right that
this is a hard problem it's a hard
problem because I just for for for the
life of me cannot see these AGI fears
and these AI say I can totally see that
look uh some people might use it to do
some some dumb stuff with it or some
some dangerous things okay okay but sort
of the oh everything's doomed fears I
cannot get on board with that yet I know
that there are extremely smart people
like Ilia sver who
are more in of that opinion right so
that in myself creates a dichotomy where
people who are clearly much smarter than
me are
concerned uh
but I kind of can't see necessarily why
like
I I feel I have a good grasp on
disagreeing with that so I don't
know that that's kind of a cognitive
dissonance that that I guess one just
has to live
with what have you learned working on
theep Judge the difference between
startup and Academia startup you
actually have to do something that
works and that helps be like actually
solves the problem in Academia you have
to solve the problem of you know
publishing papers which is Al which is
not easy right which is not easy but
it's entirely different
problem
um M model realized their existence and
their differentiation from other things
well who
knows thoughts an open
router watch open
router some of the challenges in the
open Assistant projects that were
unexpected to you how did you deal with
them um I mean nothing was too
unexpected uh it
was no nothing was too unexpected what
was most surprising is just how many
people wanted to be part of this which
was really cool really cool to see that
brought some problems man like Community
Management and managing contributors
managing bug bug reports and so on and
uh people asking for stuff but
luckily we had a lot of help like a lot
of people contributing also on the
organization code Community Management
side that was super
cool
um the best open open source alternative
to gp4 I I don't know there's a new one
every day chat more of a
question thank the work oh thank you
thank you 30 years from now I don't know
what 30 years from now is going to
be zero examples of model
escaping yeah that's
correct author interviews come back
probably they take like a ton of more
time and
[Music]
uh yeah then I mean I enjoy talking to
these people quite a bit but they take a
ton of time to prepare to postprocess
and so on uh so lacking time that was
one of the things I had was able to do
less one who got AGI first can dominate
all other companies and humans at
some yeah but then like you're you're
like people who say this they're already
in the magical land where AGI can do
just about anything um I have this thing
that you know in the argumentation in
these kind of Doom argumentations
there's always some point where you'll
have to convince me that the AGI can
write such nice
emails that they essentially can
convince anyone to do anything just by
writing very nice convincing emails that
that's there there's always a point in
the succession of like how is it going
to do this how is it going to achieve
that where it comes down to well it can
write really nice emails and I just
don't believe that no matter how nice
your emails are you can uh convince uh
you know you can achieve all of these
things that's just my opinion what you
think of
perplexity H really cool really cool I
like using perplexity um
most exciting advances in AI making real
scientific
research yeah I mean Alpha fold and
things like this are are obviously
really nice examples of uh scientific
advances um like there's a lot of
potential here and deep mind is really
on
that when using open router it's
convenient good
good all right your next plans I don't
know
survive like a website that gives API
access to a bunch of different models
mostly llama ones good
nice
cool which extends the W from
language it's an know representation yes
sure I'm um that complete like whenever
wallr starts getting into it uh that
goes over my
head will be able to create a good
enough reward function for LMS to self
learn I don't
know uh thank thank you for watching uh
are you interested in works focusing on
equivariant architectures yeah I mean
that has been going on for a long time
right and that that's obviously super
interesting if you know something about
the structure of the world can you bring
that into your your architectures and
and yeah that's that's very helpful
obviously if you
do
cool Periodic Table of circuits REM of
RNA World
hypothesis interpretability shows basic
building blocks sure there's going to be
some basic building blocks but there's
also going to be more complicated
stuff spammer would repurpose it to run
tech support scams yeah and we have spam
filters like our spam filters will get
better too and all human emails are that
convincing what do you think tiny grad
in terms of its
goal I have not looked at tiny
grad productivity tips do you have a
routine work just
work uh I thought some kind of RL was
necessary for scientific air
breakthroughs alphaa Barely Used any
right um I guess for some stuff RL is
important and for some stuff it's less
important uh if you have like a hard
optimization problem then it probably is
important um like a multi-step
optimization problem such as you know
chess or so I know that's not a hard
scientific problem but then it's
probably
important would you say the main reason
for stopping it's that yeah concluding
it people are at capacity limits and are
moving on having other interests and uh
that's that's
okay there's research in hierarchical
word
embeddings yeah yeah that's those that's
that exists and for some use is it's
very good are you still working on deep
charge
yes okay this
code this is is cursed uh but
essentially like this should really be
handled with uh with um a select or
something like
this is it
even yeah it's it's a weight um so this
this would usually be handled with like
a a select routine or something like
this in a in a good or a poll like pole
will probably be the the correct thing
to do here so you uh have these these
call backs here where what you do is you
have all these workers right you have
all these websockets and you want the
one backend um threed here to watch all
of them and whenever anything is sent on
any of them you want to listen to it you
want to get it and you want to react to
it right at the same time you also have
a all the cues so that every worker can
connect to a que and every que is
connected to a front-end chat so this
piece of the code here does the mapping
between which worker is currently
working on which chat and then tries to
do the the routing so you
um you
you look at all the pending Futures
right which is
uh all the things that you're waiting
for and you go you go over them so if it
is
a um Tuple I guess oh then it's
something if
then otherwise it's a work
response ah a worker response okay this
here comes from the worker so you case
it out if it's pong a token generate a
text an error some other stuff and what
you do for example if it's a
token you go here you can
see
you get the message cue that this is
that the chat is listening to and you
and Q the response into that message CU
right and then on the other hand on the
other side in the
chats
um on the other side you want
to DQ stuff now where are
we see on the other on the other side if
the frontend subscribes to these events
you're going to listen to that redis q
and you're going to make an event
generator so here is the message CU
you're going to listen to
that and you're going to DQ successively
from that message CU and then send that
across um across to the client as a
response and there's a whole bunch of
stuff happening in between but
eventually you'll send that generator
back now this here was really the bane
of the existence that's also something
that
um I had
not I had not uh really thought through
there are routines in redis that make
this a lot easier but to maintain which
position you're in the queue I maintain
these uh DQ and NQ counter which were
essentially pointers into the que of
where stuff is and where you are
currently and that would be a you'll be
able to tell which position you are in
the queue however there's some
concurrency issue with these that made
it such that slowly over time this
number kept shifting and therefore at
some point it said like you're number
800 in the queue when there was just
like maybe 20 30 people in front of you
in the queue so every now and then I do
just wipe reddis uh and fully and then
that would kind of reset but
yeah all right that was that was that
um poll fast API poll yes yes yes yes
yes this could be done much more nicely
with pole could be done with reddish
Primitives or or reddis Pipelines and um
we should be good how large is the open
Assistant data set I think it's in total
over a 100,000 uh interactions um about
10,000 message trees I think use The
Primitives yes I know I know this was
not this was not the most you know
cleanest implementation but it was an
implementation and it served ton it
served like five to 10 messages a second
I believe at the height so you know
pretty pretty good for like and it
didn't crash it was powered by a ton of
gpus you know at the moment like at the
peak of everything
so it it was fine it was good it was it
did its job and yeah now the the back
end for the data
collection that was that's as I said is
better
implemented uh so so like the tree
manager is a core class here the tree
manager um tries to do all of the kind
of see is the prompt Lottery where we
select new prompts inversely
proportional to the how many so if I
submit 100 prompts I shouldn't my my
prompts shouldn't be more likely to get
chosen than someone who submits three
prompts and so on there's Auto
moderation
determin task availability see this
stuff you actually know what it does
when you look at it right and it's very
clean very good and yeah so the tree
manager is really one of the central
pieces of code right here so see uh low
grade
State um check
conditions this is all it's all quite
clean and uh quite well done the user
system is just screwed up that's my
fault uh totally over engineered look at
these queries beautiful
beautiful
um
then yeah then the the front
end the web front
and that's the that's also very
beautiful so like all of this is just
look types typed well it's International
ized it's with server site
rendering it's all like wow very cool
even the chat so beautiful beautiful
beautiful code right here the front end
is front end and the back end a
beautiful code can copilot chat improve
the code sure it
can
uh autom moderate AGI
block T unpack instead of indexing
slicing sure sure sure like lots of
stuff possible but
uh yeah animated
circle look at this so
pretty not an error in the
world all right but I really can't
explain you too much about this part of
the code base except for saying that it
worked really well
um
and yeah that's that's
that other than that I I don't know I I
haven't done too much here I've done
some some small things in the front end
but really not
much uh and there are there were tests
even tests imagine
that yeah so the code is still available
like uh you can just Docker compose it
up and you'll get the whole system up
that's completely
completely possible
um
and yeah you can you can use it it's all
out there it's ay licensed I think
so outsmart everyone
Implement
okay that is a prediction
indeed nobody have should ever have to
write code like this by hand again I
kind of doubt like okay the copilot
already helped help s with a lot of code
writing but I kind of doubt we'll stop
writing code just
because just
because all right I think I think I'll
head out a little bit
um it's good to
chat and we'll be around I I have a
tradition now to do Minecraft live
streams over Christmas so I hopefully
I'll get to do one or two of those as
well
actually last year's this time around
like over Christmas was the uh time when
I started
working I um streamed work on open
started on open Assistant
coding and
yeah that that was really this was just
about a
year uh yeah so I wish everyone bought
aviator sunglasses because of you thank
you
uh yeah they're they're good because you
know they allow me to look at the screen
because I think if a if so you see
someone in sunglasses that's an effect I
didn't intend right uh that just it just
happens to be the case is that it feels
much more like I'm looking into the
camera whereas actually I'm looking at
the screen uh and where if I didn't have
the glasses then obviously it' be very
visible uh that I'm not looking at the
camera but you know I have to read stuff
so the huging face Hub
rep uh no I'm just kind of I'm just kind
of interested in how it's it's made you
know uh just out of Interest I thought
today you know that wasn't obviously
would have
been going through the open Assistant
code Bas is obviously this like the the
more obvious choice I just thought to
have something on the screen all right
that's it thank you for being here thank
you for uh getting along to for anyone
who's contributed to open Assistant uh
thank you very much for that it was
really cool and I hope uh by finishing
it when at a time when it's good uh we
it's going to be something that can be
remembered um in you know just as as a
good thing that happened that's it all
right
goodbyes